uh we'll join me in our defense and
security analyst Professor Michael
Clarke and Mike I want to talk to you
about those air strikes because we're
learning a bit more about the Fallout
from them the president saying around 85
has struck across the country and and in
terms of the damage they're doing talk
to us about what we know what's coming
out of Ukraine today yes I mean this is
just uh the same as the Russians did
when the Kirsch straight Bridge was hit
two days later about a hundred
airstrikes missiles and drones all
across the country this looks to be
about the same sort of level in in
places that we know of so far
going for critical infrastructure but
also quite a lot of Civilian sites they
don't kill so many people but they
certainly de-house a lot of people and
it it's Revenge because that's what the
Kremlin wants to show but it's also
um part of the domestic argument in
Russia it's to give the Russians some
sense that the war is going on is
vigorous even though the Newsome person
is quite bad so it's partly a
distraction technique as well and just
looking over the border of Ukraine into
Moldova we're hearing about large power
outages in Moldova that needs just
coming into us this afternoon which
gives you a sense of obviously how the
region is so linked and the danger not
just to Ukraine but further afield as
well it is Moldova has in it a breakaway
region that's not declared itself
Breakaway yet transnistria with a
Russian minority it was the headquarters
of the old 14th Army in the in the Red
Army days Moldova is a very
um I don't want to call it unstable but
its stability is always in some doubt
and what happens in Ukraine really
affects Moldova and it's not surprising
that their their infrastructure is so
linked life is tough in Moldova as it is
and they're right on the edge of a war
zone they stopped doing them any good at
all yeah and they're feeling the effects
of those air strikes and you know as you
said the targeting of critical
infrastructure let's talk about her son
and obviously the retreat of Russian
troops there but where did those troops
go talk to us about what's happening
around on her son and further afield yes
I mean her son itself the Russians got
about 30 000 troops out of the the area
and they did it pretty well um
clandestinely at night with on civilian
Vehicles they had
um civilian buses military buses
civilian buses military buses going in
convoys it looked as if they're getting
civilians out but they weren't they were
getting military out alongside them they
did it really rather cleverly they
seemed to have got most of the 30 000
out my guess is they want to send most
of those troops up to the donbass where
they will make some difference because
these are quite good troops that they
had there and my guess is that they will
want to try to hold this position on the
the East Bank of the Nipper River while
they send the bulk of troops up to the
where the fighting is now really facing
the donbass meanwhile the ukrainians
have crossed to the south side of the
river we didn't think that they would at
this stage but they're keeping going and
so they've landed we know now on the
kinburn peninsula and they're moving
along the kimbern peninsula and the
Russians look as if they're putting up a
defense west of rebelce uh the
ukrainians we know are in hiroski and so
somewhere on that narrow neck of land
only about four kilometers wide there is
now a battle going on and also the
Russians expect the ukrainians to try to
cross onto the South side at novakovka
that looks like a pretty big thing if
they do that's a big operation if they
make it but the Russians certainly think
they're going to try so the ukrainians
are keeping the battle going they're not
sitting on the Laurels they're trying to
pressurize Russian forces to get them to
pull back even further get them out of
artillery range of the city of Kirsten
for a start and there are all sorts of
rumors going on about what's happening
in between Nova Kafka and the kinburn
peninsula and I think in the next 48
hours we'll hear a lot more about what's
going on along that River yeah a lot
going on in the region around
Hearthstone in person itself mooted
celebrations with his team president
zielinski in there some sense of relief
but it's the donbass that we're looking
at as well you mentioned the donbass
region and while there is some sense of
celebration in Hearthstone I mean far
from it in a Doncaster you know when he
was when he he was celebrating you
Kirsten I mean president zelenski he I
thought he had the thousand yard stare
of warfare I mean people talk about this
the thousand yard stare that soldiers
developed and that's what he had and he
said it is hell in the dombas and he's
not wrong because there is fighting
going on all along this front the
Russians are pushing really hard at
places like marife
the Wagner group have been launching
endless attacks on back mode and these
are almost human wave attacks they're
just putting convicts in the case of the
Wagner group and mobilized soldiers in
the front line the reserves are behind
them with instructions to shoot them if
they if they pull back or they withdraw
and the real battle is going on between
svato and cremina because the ukrainians
are determined to take this p-66 highway
which which is critical for reasons that
you can see as you see it on the map and
the ukrainians are quite close to
actually taking that Highway more or
less in the middle between svatovi and
cremina and to take both places but they
haven't managed it yet and the Russians
are fighting tooth and nail to hang onto
this for tovi and criminal because if
they lose it particularly cremina that
is the gateway to the uh to um Donetsk
to the second part of the Republic the
gateway to severed on yet remember that
100 days I mean if they get to criminal
they can get around the back of
sovereign and all sorts of other things
become possible but the Russians are not
going to give that up easily okay
Michael thank you Professor Michael
Clarke for the latest there on what's
unfolding on the ground in Ukraine